75% des femmes préfèrent les hommes avec
un ventre ah ah ah ouais à regret c'est
pas un truc de ouf ça gré sinon ça veut
dire tu te fais chier toute l'année pour
avoir des tablettes de chocolat et on
sait km à 75 % elle préfère les mecs
alors parce qu'on a on va tout ce truc
ou genre tapez votre monde et jaka fm et
a priori pas du tout je ne mangeais et
frère ça fait six ans non mais ça reste
forte en quoi aussi répliqué attention
hein pas non plus la grosse bedaine bien
sûr le petit bidon un peu douillet un
peu voilà un peu nous nous rejouer dans
son sens je pense que vous montez donc
en fait genre vous aider les ventes mais
en fait quand vous avez voilà vous
préférez les tables non non non
attention parce que le garçon qui a des
tablettes de chocolat
ça fait un peu celui qui s'occupe
vraiment que de lui de son corps à peu
centré sur lui-même et que c'est à
travers moi j'ai pas de tablette de
chocolat et je ne m'occupe que de moi
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas de nuages et une crise aussi
bien côté comme ça vous voilà en tête et
les bahamas et bien vous êtes dit choisi
d'imposer la télé oui l'un des sinon oui
c'est vrai parce que quand c'est trop
c'est que ça fait trop corps jeune trop
jeune en fête bat son mensonge et
hébétude moins salée puisque hors bons
sont en fait des ventes saint domingue
et très sec 1 quand même
non alors il gatto c'est qu'ils trouvent
dans un coûteux et dont il était sec
quand je les ai rencontrés il ya cinq
ans maintenant plus et du coup juste un
peu dessus moi je trouve que c'est une
belle facture et les vieilles vignes
maire sexy et ben ouais si delphine le
dis franchement balle a alors que si moi
je le dis on s'en fout c'est bon ça n'a
rien à voir baisser que de la dette fidh
elle est avec roger et donc forcément le
connais des personnes voilà qui ont fait
un long voyage mais s'est rattachée
s'est rattachée à la protection est
presque au papa tiens c'est un retour
c'est quand on est un peu de bidons
comme ça là on a tous un peu de bidons
c'est pour les femmes ça leur fait
plaisir s'est rattaché un peu au papa
l'affection à l'encadrement la
protection des mois on est dans la dark
eye psychologies magazine
alors magali merdouille comme la fille
d'auguste un verre d'eau moi je n'ai pas
menti un beau corps avec un beau ventre
bien plat et des hammams sexy la dubai
mais non mais ça fait mascotte de
joystick et à dubaï c'est le seul
endroit même au restaurant le soir tu
arrives en maillot les gars c'est comme
dans sous le soleil est là ils ont toute
la journée en maillot les gars le mec
dans son ensemble a été un autre caïd
jouer va payer cette série sous le
soleil ce qui est seule gâte arashiro
[ __ ] et opéré opération du coeur en
politique
30 il ya vraiment la balle au rebond
non mais c'est vrai quoi fatma qu'il a
des abdos et bien sûr mais finit une
sorte d'opération tribu madrague aussi
les abdos alors chez universal ils ont
dessiné en voici la preuve encore avec
deux adolescents mais c'est vrai ça
existe si vous dessine les abdos alors
non mais où ils font tout et n'importe
quoi que tu leur donnes une une trousse
ils te font un truc de dingue 2 foot ces
gens là on a plein d'idées
les faits datent uruguay ce qu'ils
connaissent à nouveau alors ça c'est un
vrai scoop
[Applaudissements]
là c'est dans le chalet scoop mais là
alors on attend juste il est fait de
l'action il a fait de la chose est déjà
sûre avec moi il a fait nip aussi sur la
forme et le temps d'un vigile
ouais bah ça se fait en même temps dans
l'es2 les à-côtés l'incident les deux
nés à côté
ouais on les avait fait des articles
et/ou l'actuel c'est génial ouais c est
après vous avez quand même à souffrir
seul alors il a souffert avec moi ah
ouais moi aussi je prenais j'avais la
pression alors moi non c'est pas se
comprendre ses téléspectateurs mais moi
quelle angoisse de faire une liposuccion
et que ça fait c'est quoi ça elle meurt
plus vous il ya du boulot quand même là
oui mais bon c'est pas grave il faut
également cité à rennes nantes est
parfait non mais là il m'a été dit pas
ça non mais vous avez un corps de
sportive vous le savez très bien vous
êtes vous ai nommé c'est le malaise je
suis dur partout là ouais après j'ai eu
une petite molette ici puisque pour les
abdos en fait il de rêve le gras au
milieu et en fait tu le gardes du gras
et tu fais il fonde et créer un chèque
de la grèce c'est horrible c'est bizarre
c'est beau ça va c'est une fête chez
tout le monde n'a pas dû parce que vous
continuez votre régime parce que vous en
parlez pas oui ça moi je prépare mon nom
c'est que j'arrête
à temps
celle ci s'est fait livrer 27 tonnes de
compote
ouais ouais c'est oh bah ouais et alors
pas les fruits dont on écoute et pas les
autres
ils ont reçu tous les jours non non non
non non elle sort a dit williams et que
je vous racontais hier j'étais au gbl
merguez ya ça ne comporte en soirée des
jeudis vous mentez voulez que je vous
dise très mauvaise émission